[Music]
with her trademark bob
and dark sunglasses anna winter rules
the 300 billion
american fashion universe anna is the
single most influential individual
in the world of fashion as editor of
vogue magazine
she's become a celebrity herself
with a reputation as fairy godmother to
some
anna winter's approval is important
anything i do
and fire breathing dragon to others i've
heard names ice queen
nuclear winter i'm sure she's demanding
to get results you do have to be
demanding
is she warm and fuzzy no why should
she have to be her influence has moved
beyond the pages of the glossy magazine
she's a pacesetter and power broker
she is the woman that brought fashion to
big business
and to the world globally
[Music]
i i don't know anything about uh fashion
and i don't read vogue regularly but i
know a lot about you
vogue editor anna winter confronted her
storied reputation head-on
in a rare late-night television
appearance i read in the new york times
this week that i'm
an ice queen i'm the sun king
i'm an alien fleeing from district 9 and
i'm a dominatrix
so i reckon that makes me a lukewarm
royalty with a whip
from outer space what do you think a
good gig
[Applause]
[Music]
her gig is editor-in-chief of vogue
magazine
for 22 years the powerful and
intimidating queen bee
has told women what and who to wear
long skirts are short royal blue or navy
or that gray is the new black i adore
fashion i adore
what it says about women vogue has a
recognition that no other magazine has
and that
it's deeply satisfying to me anna is
revolutionary
she's she revolutionized the whole
modern fashion industry
anna is someone who responds to
competitiveness
in a way that you wish everyone did
she doesn't get angry she gets even
winter manages her media profile
carefully and declined to participate in
this program
[Music]
anna winter was ambitious from a young
age born in london in 1949
she dropped out of school it was the
sixties and she was captivated by
london's cultural
and social scene her mother eleanor
was american and her british father
charles was the hard-nosed
editor-in-chief
of the london newspaper the evening
standard
lori schechter began her career as anna
winter's assistant
she grew up in a home with a journalist
a newsman there's a certain standard and
rigor of work
there that definitely got passed on to
her
and is the way she approaches everything
that she does now
when she was 20 winter got her
well-dressed foot in the door
at the newly formed british magazine
harpers and queen
she was intensely competitive she angled
to work with the best photographers to
climb up the ladder
but after five years at harper's and
queen she was passed over for the
position of editor-in-chief
she left the magazine and england and in
1975
headed to new york's 7th avenue vera
wang
sits on top of her own fashion empire
and has known winter for over 30 years
she was not anna winter high priestess
of vogue
she was my friend and we were two girls
that were looking
to get something going in the fashion
industry and anna was
definitely set about going to the
magazine business and and particularly
vogue
but vogue would have to wait winter's
first job in new york was at harper's
bazaar
she was fired for being as she claimed
in a newspaper interview to european
after a few months without work she
accepted a job offer from penthouse
magazine publisher
bob guccione as fashion editor at viva
an erotic magazine for women her fashion
layouts won recognition
a few years later she landed her first
big job
fashion editor at new york magazine she
was
a complete mystery fascinating mystery
she
wore the dark glasses pretty much 100 of
the time
it is sink or swim she tells you what
she wants and she's not gonna tell you
how to do it i lost eight pounds in two
weeks and it's just because it was
constant winter was building a
reputation for stylish layouts and a
relentless work ethic
she had a very set agenda
she has had the courage and the guts
and the intelligence and the energy to
do all of this
it wasn't long before the executives at
conde nast
cy new house and alexander lieberman
took notice
tom florio was the publishing director
at vogue and has known winter for 30
years
in those early days of conde nast it
almost felt like a young hollywood
studio
you know and mr newhouse with alex just
had this great
sense of how to build not only magazines
but personalities to lead these
magazines the organization really
embraced people with vision
and determination and drive no one had
more of that drive than anna winter she
was rewarded with a job at vogue
created just for her it wasn't the job
she was aiming for
that was already taken by long-time
editor-in-chief
grace mirabella there was obviously
resistance but when anna comes in
she's not a wallflower and she's going
to make her point of view known and
that's why she was brought there
winter's point of view was not welcomed
by mirabella
in her autobiography mirabella described
the new creative director
as cold and suspicious always working
against her to undermine her authority
she wrote that she felt winter was being
groomed for her job
i think there were those who felt
threatened
they didn't know her they didn't know
quite why she was there
and they weren't going to necessarily
welcome anyone new
let alone someone like anna who
cut quite a striking figure caught your
eye
and definitely had the attention
of the major decision makers at conde
nest
[Music]
after a three-year power struggle conde
nast put an
ocean between them they offered winter a
promotion to editor-in-chief
of british vogue
moving up the corporate ladder brought
new excitement
but it came at a tough personal cost she
moved to london with her new baby
while her husband stayed behind in new
york
anna winter arrived in london in 1986
and immediately began to alter the shape
of british vogue in some ways
she brought it more down to earth for
those who wanted to maybe actually
find things that they could buy and made
it
more serviceable for the reader
the readers may have enjoyed the change
but her staff
was not as accepting they gave her a
nickname that stuck
nuclear winter it's a little bit the
greta garbo
thing if you don't say a lot and don't
sort of engage
people but that you know then leaves the
rest of the world
to make up what they think is the truth
is she warm and fuzzy you know
no why should she have to be is she
someone you'd like her opinion
absolutely after 18 months conde nast
brought their up-and-coming star
back to new york to overhaul their
shelter magazine
house and garden winter changed the
title to
hg out were photos of empty rooms
in were lavish spreads of celebrities in
their homes
readers revolted and the magazine was
forced to hand out subscription refunds
terry agens is a former senior fashion
writer for the wall street journal
and the author of the end of fashion i
mean that's why i call anna
revolutionary because i mean
even her plan to like come in and do
something that radical to
a an established magazine the
prospect for failure is high when you do
something that
that gutsy these failures would have
ended many a career
but not anna winters conde nast still
had
other plans for her it was the worst
kept secret in the fashion world
there had been rumors that miss wintour
would become the editor of american
vogue replacing the veteran grace
mirabella well now the hot publishing
story is that this probably will happen
after 17 years mirabella was out
38 year old anna winter got the job she
always wanted
her vision was clear from her first
cover she paired a ten
thousand dollar top with forty dollar
jeans that
signaled something new revolutionary
this was a new editor
she was british she was stylish she was
young
and you know and she really had a point
of view
we knew that this was going to be a new
era in a december 1988 interview
winter explained what it takes to be
editor-in-chief of vogue
that i think is what's so important in
in this job is to have the right kind of
instinct and gut reaction to produce a
magazine that is
of the moment that just captures what's
going on
right now i mean that's what it is to be
involved
[Music]
mirabella's traditional head shots were
replaced with winter's fresh new look
she spared no expense on elaborate photo
shoots with the best photographers
[Music]
anna knew just how to balance our desire
for escape
and for beauty and for real fashion
with our need to have things that are
relevant to us as women
things that fit into our lifestyle and
who we are and where we've come
once again winter saw the allure of
celebrities
and replaced supermodels with superstars
on the cover filmmaker r.j cutler
very early on anna wintour saw
that celebrity power
global industry and fashion were all
coming together
we had the mega brands gucci prada
lvmh working women became executive
women
and so they needed power suits for work
she understood the glamour of high
fashion
the desire to make people dream to
aspire
to inspire but she also understood how
fashion as a business had changed
[Music]
winter's growing reputation captured
increased
advertising dollars ed nardoza is the
editor of women's wear daily
the advertising business can be very
fickle you have to build
loyalty over time you have to provide
real value
and reasons for advertisers to
consistently stay in your publications
because it is
one of the most competitive industries
in the world
in 10 years ad revenues climbed from
just over 87 million dollars
to nearly 150 million dollars
vogue success brought winter increased
power
her front row appearances at fashion
shows wearing her trademark dark glasses
took on new meaning every glacial
expression
was scanned for clues
and became someone very important to
have at your show
when she's there it validates the show
that the show was
cool that means that the show is like a
big deal
vogue under winter was on a journey from
magazine
to brand success brought winter
increased public scrutiny
in 1999 the tabloids ran with the story
of her divorce
and her relationship with millionaire
texas communications executive
shelby bryant people gossip and
and speculate about her every move but
she has just basically risen above it
and i think it's a smart thing to do
undistracted
winter was focusing her attention on
what was ahead for vogue
her answer was invariably the same
people are always asking what was that
your favorite collection was that your
favorite issue and it to me it's always
the next one
it's the it's the idea of what is to
come it's always the future
always the future most editors don't
think
beyond their title but anna thinks about
the world and how it impacts the title
also how the title can impact the world
charles townsend is the ceo of conde
nast publications
she's involved in all aspects of the
globe brand whether it's
marketing the brand to the consumer
whether it's marketing the brand to the
advertising community
you know it's political influence it's
social influence she
manages that brand's positioning
across all of those parameters
to extend the brand in 2003 she launched
teen vogue men's vogue and vogue living
followed in one year
ad revenue for men's vogue dropped over
one million dollars
in 2008 conde nast cut it to an
occasional supplement
u.s vogue living disappeared only teen
vogue survived on the newsstands
the brand extension didn't quite work
but those were natural and productive
experiments
she takes risks she works really really
hard
and when life doesn't work she's she
brushes it off and she recovers and just
tries to learn from the situation and
move on
winter's increased visibility and her
public support of the fur industry
attracted some wild confrontations
during the height of the anti-firm
movement
you know anna was defined she was
wearing her furs
the protesters would show up at the
shows
she was having lunch at the four seasons
and someone put a dead animal
in her plate if you're walking through
paris and somebody hits you with a pie
and knocks you down
that's pretty aggressive anybody else
would have been upset
she stood up wiped her face she said
this is getting really boring went back
to the hotel changed and made her next
meeting
after that she started to get protection
she comes into the show and she's
accompanied by these two bodyguards
this also helps stoke the myth that
she's
you know in a class by herself she dug
in her
stylish stilettos never wavering in her
support for the multi-billion dollar fur
industry
the more her reputation grew the more
unwelcome attention she got
the novel the devil wears prada was
considered by many in the fashion
industry to be a thinly disguised and
devastating portrayal of winter
the hollywood version starring meryl
streep was a huge hit
grossing over 326 million dollars in
theaters
that i like at worldwide store get us a
reservation for dinner tonight at that
place
[Music]
this dragon lady reputation or is often
portrayed
i think there's some kind of gender
issue here because she's a woman
people expect her to behave a certain
way and
i think if she were a ceo running a
company
there would be no issue
[Music]
winter was now a recognized power broker
with wide-reaching relationships
throughout the fashion industry
she's been very instrumental in many of
the
very large brands when they were looking
for
a standard bearer or a creator or a
designer
or a creative director she has been
instrumental in helping those brands
succeed as well
[Music]
one brand that needed her help was gap
for years the company had been suffering
from declining sales
they consulted winter and she
recommended young designer
patrick robinson so i think she called
me and that's just what my thoughts were
and
sort of gave me some thoughts about what
the job sort of could look like
more from how she saw it and just as a
per it was more personal
so it was that simple but she was this
great sounding board
for me when i was thinking about the job
her matchmaking worked
in 2007 robinson became gap's new
executive vice president of design
anna winter's approval is important
anything i do it still
is she's the first steal to this day
that sees everything i do
but after four years of lackluster
results the gap
dismissed its star designer winter's
interest in supporting new talent
led her to create the vogue fashion fund
to provide grants and business advice
you have to keep that feeder system
going anna was really
interested in making certain we continue
to have
more designers which means more
advertisers
and more sales so all this works
together
everything came together in september
2007
when winter delivered the fall season
premiere issue of vogue
the magazine had a record-breaking 727
pages of
anyone coming to advertising run through
except for me it became the subject of
the hit documentary the september issue
a rare look inside vogue and the
demanding woman running
it's gorgeous i'm not crazy about this
one thing we should do you know
she looks
[Music]
this type seems so large and pretentious
looks like it's for blind people
dana does not look back she looks
forward she does not doubt she trusts
herself
she requires a thick skin but you know
even a thick skin
has nerves under it she would need steel
nerves in 2009
we found ourselves facing economic
circumstances
through the recession that we never
imagined were possible
[Music]
in 2009 the deepest recession in decades
was forcing business to slash
advertising dollars
vogue's ad sales for the all-important
september issue
plunged from 727 pages in 2007
to 429 in 2009
conde nast is a private company that
does not publicly report financial
results
clearly the company was under pressure
they shuttered six of their magazines
and cut hundreds of jobs
but their crown jewel vogue managed its
costs
and managed to escape drastic cuts
seventh avenue was also being squeezed
by a shopping slowdown
winter took on a new mission new yorkers
they're always in fashion always in
fashion her idea was a worldwide retail
extravaganza
called fashion's night out fashion
industry is counting on you
thank you for coming out tonight it
turned out
that this was an unprecedented event
that brought together over a thousand
retailers around the world
and thousands and thousands of consumers
flooded the stores
[Music]
it was so successful that it has become
an annual event
we want to thank everybody for coming
out how y'all feeling tonight
[Applause]
winter also stepped in to save one of
new york city's treasures
the costume institute at the
metropolitan museum of art
as fundraiser in chief she hosts the
annual gala
it was something that rivaled even the
oscars
emily rafferty is president of the
metropolitan museum of art
this last year we raised in one night uh
through her leadership over nine million
dollars
even in a time of recession
[Music]
there are other formidable challenges in
front of winter
con has admittedly been slow to adapt to
the digital
age now vogue and winter's future
depend on it any monthly magazine
really needs to examine that there's
demand
for immediate information how do you
supply that demand
her monthly magazine faces increasing
competition from bloggers
and interactive websites that have given
designers a new platform to instantly
showcase their designs
and simultaneously sell their products
relying less
on glossy photo spreads in vogue this
season philip lim is all about outerwear
winter now shares the coveted front row
with new media
i guarantee you that anna will
change the game of digitized content
we're taking branded content
with her voice to millions of consumers
that we couldn't possibly touch
with a magazine as an exclusive medium
winter her colleagues and critics alike
believe
has transcended the medium she has
become
the curator of worldwide fashion
[Applause]
[Music]
anna does something almost every day
that's huge
she always has an idea of pushing this
industry and sort of pushing it further
and further
this is a multi-hundred
billion dollar global industry and that
is a byproduct of many things but one of
them
is anna's stewardship of vogue magazine
in 20-plus years she's got this
incredible reference point
of what good fashion is
and what talent is and what creativity
is
she's not here just to say whether a
dress looks nice or not
or whether a new shoe is groovy enough
she's really there to encourage the
entire industry
young talent established talent these
are all difficult balls to keep in there
but
she feels that this is her duty
this is her legacy as well
she is the woman that brought fashion
really to big business
and to the world globally